oh
[Musique]
plus grand combat ça n'a pas été les
jeux olympiques ça a été surtout me
faire accepter dans ce milieu d'hommes
quand je suis entré la première fois
dans une salle de boxe il y avait une
cinquantaine d'hommes qui s'entraînait
et il n'y avait pas de place pour une
femme d'ailleurs il y avait pas du
vestiaire les équipements étaient pas du
tout adapté moi je me souviens de mon
premier protège poitrine et c'est un
gros truc en plastique avec de gros
tétons qu'il a fallu que je lis mme pour
pour pouvoir boxer je pense que quelque
part nous titiller un peu l'orgueil des
hommes
je crois qu'en revenant sur sur un ring
sur le terrain de certains boxeurs ou
c'était un peu le lieu où ils pouvaient
s'affirmer
je crois que ça les dérangeait
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à m'entraîner en 96 sauf
qu'on a eu l'autorisation de boxer en
compétition qu'à partir de 99 avant ça
on pouvait s'entraîner dans les salles
de boxe quand les entraîneurs voulaient
bien nous accepter ce qui était assez
rare et puis en 99 on a eu enfin
l'autorisation de faire des combats
amateurs faut savoir qu'en france on
était un des derniers pays en europe à à
légaliser les la compétition en boxe
anglaise pour les femmes le public
n'était pas habitué à voir des femmes
sur un ring hormis les ring girls celle
avec des pancartes et des maillots de
bain mais mais c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué parce qu'il fallait faire sa
place se faire respecter
et ça ça a pris du temps il a fallu
vraiment se battre dans le sens où il
fallait venir à l'entraînement tous les
jours montré qu'on était capable de
faire la belle boxe de tenir des combats
physiquement et tactiquement aussi bien
que les hommes
et puis à un deuxième moment dans ma
carrière où je sens que j'ai vraiment
dérangé c'est après ma grossesse ou là
clairement m'a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
accepter qu'une maman tu montes sur un
ring je crois que ça pouvait déranger et
souvent d'ailleurs dans
dans le sport on pense que la maternité
signe l'arrêt de de la carrière alors
que pour moi ça a été une vraie force en
fait de devenir maman
mais ça il a fallu le prouver
ça c'est un mets premier combat ça a été
de dire j'ai envie de boxer laissez moi
et puis maintenant que j'ai raccroché
les gants c'est faire en sorte qu'il y
ait plus de femmes qui osent monter sur
un ring mais aussi qui ose prendre des
postes de dirigeante dans les
fédérations en france mais aussi à
l'international des femmes qui entraîne
des équipes féminines mais aussi
masculine
donc voilà c'est surtout faire en sorte
que les femmes prennent des places quoi
dans ce monde-là qui reste quand même
encore très réservé aux hommes